so mike tyson mike tyson said maybe a
fight with you
because now i'm really curious about the
tyson thing i think everybody else is as
well but we're gonna get back to your
[ __ ] okay but that was really
[ __ ] good
though
yeah
he's seven and four in the streets
if this fight takes place on pavement
bro you never know if there's a curb
we can do a pay-per-view spar if you
want we can set that up yeah nobody's
fighting here
everything i owned making this goddamn
studio what kind of dude
you know the pay-per-views
wtf media studios
so but mike tyson goes
mike tyson goes yeah maybe we could do a
fight
mm-hmm you think you [ __ ] up mike tyson
who is now much older
right
heavily under the influence
but i i would win
you would win and i think
come on
come on out ow
you're a hater bro are you serious bro
serious is a heart attack i respect you
and your brother you guys have
delusional confidence like it's amazing
so
delusional optimism yes yes all right
now it's uh it's a real superpower it is
um dude this is mike tyson bro dude
that's
you know i i will start off by saying
i love mike tyson i love him his family
he's such a great guy such a wise guy
he's taking me under his wing
and
owe him a ton of credit for helping me
start my career with the nate robinson
fight on it on his undercard oh that's
right um
we forget that's crazy yeah we forget
that
same night yeah that was that no that
was the main card
but oh wow and you were doing some cool
[ __ ] afterwards where you were going i
sold a million pay-per-views like mike
wasn't on the [ __ ] car
he helped a little bit
okay but go get where you can get it get
it boy all right so go on so tyson is
you know he's cool he's the og
but at the same time you think if you
guys were in the ring together i think
he thinks that he would knock me out and
i think that is maybe the reason why
he doesn't want to do the fight because
i think he wants to
avoid maybe knocking me out like hurting
you or doing something yeah he doesn't
realize how good you are exactly if he
knew
maybe he would
maybe the fight would happen can you
invite him to a spa or something not him
sparring but just to watch you work
[Applause]
maybe you know maybe maybe him watching
this would help do you think you can
knock him out can i ask you a question i
think there's a very very high chance of
that yeah
yes he's not the same
he's not the same fighter that he once
was and he knows that stop it you think
you could beat up every white guy what
are you talking about
i think it's a great fight i think it is
a great fight for that exact reason
me boxing on the outside him trying to
come forward to knock me out i have one
punch power he has one punch power
who wins
bro now
can i ask you a question this is serious
if mike tyson was the exact same person
that he is now
only he was white
could you beat up mike tyson i have to
train for a couple months
i'll have to trade for a little bit you
could be tyson fury
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we don't know bro he got all his food in
our fridge
we got 17 made meals in our refrigerator
because i'm bulking i'm trying to get
the heavy weight but it's still there
you're gonna deliver it here which is
weird yeah he hit me he was like why am
i going to the studio to deliver food to
markets yeah who's who are you getting
food from from my boy brian shout out to
brian gwinner yeah why aren't y'all
telling me that you're getting food no
you don't need it bro come on son
you got to get a nutritionist i really
do yeah who's your nutritionist
one of my coaches danny oh danny yeah
yeah he's nice of that yeah he's real
nice do you talking [ __ ] to him yeah
you'll cook that [ __ ]
knock you out
[ __ ]
are you taking my carbs away and i i get
upset you get a little saucy a little
hangry right yeah a little saucy right
for sure what what
it's good it's good to be on edge when
you're in fight camp oh you think
yeah what is like a
caged up animal ready to fight
[Music]